[Musique]
le nouveau directeur de l'ot sm lorquet
symphonique de montréal le vénézuélien
rafael paillard et va désormais se
partager entre montréal et san diego
californie
[Musique]
car il y est aussi directeur musical
jusqu'en 2026
[Musique]
le cor français
c'est l'instrument que le jeune raphaël
paillard et a choisi à ses débuts au
venezuela
voici pourquoi un jour il entend son
grand frère répété sa musique dans sa
chambre la tension y est mais la
marseillaise a créé le droid
[Musique]
peu après il rencontre le chef
d'orchestre du système à l'école
orchestral de sa ville
puerto la cruz antoine duhamel français
spécialiste des cuivres il le convoque à
une audition il a 14 ans et au quai
antoine duhamel quitte le venezuela
quand le président hugo chavez impose
plus de musique populaire aux systema il
rentre en europe mais il trouve le monde
de la musique trop élitiste hama il
repart pour la bolivie où il enseigne
aux enfants
il y décède en 2019 deuxième rencontre
décisive
le chef d'orchestre italien giuseppe
sinopoli
il vient jouer l'ouverture de rien dit
de wagner avec l' orchestre national des
jeunes du venezuela dont raphaël fait
partie et la même impression lucho pour
que nous autres matchs au total et
walcker cambio des thèmes pour
reconstituer leur épargne à celle de
l'ouverture à les relancer
et elle sonia look attaquant but reprend
question de ce monde riche en mmmm
partir du moment où elles prennent goût
sans nipple et les directions communs
sont contre sa permanence à yokohama
enfin il y à cette discussion avec le
fondateur du système à creuser antonio
abreu
il veut lui dire qu'il aimerait bien
jouer du corps en solo le maître c'est
tout de lui et il lui mais aux crocs
c'est qu'on a mené sa vie en rose et
antonio abreu décédé en 2018 était un
visionnaire et la suite de la carrière
de raphaël paillard et restent à
découvrir
[Musique]